what does period and frequency mean the
period is the number of seconds it takes
for a process to complete an entire
cycle circle or revolution so if there's
some repeating process the time it takes
that process to reset is the period and
it's measured in seconds the frequency
is the number of cycles or circles or
revolutions completed in one second so
if there's some process that's repeating
the number of times the process repeats
in one second would be the frequency
this means as units of one over second
which is just called the Hertz and
because the period and frequency are
defined in this inverse way as seconds
per cycle or cycles per second each one
is just the inverse of the other in
other words the period is just one over
the frequency and the frequency is equal
to one over the period one example of a
repeating process is an object going in
a circle at a constant speed if this is
the case you can relate the speed the
radius of the circle and the period of
the motion since speed is just a
distance per time and the distance the
object travels in one cycle is two PI R
the circumference the speed would just
be 2 PI R / the period or since one over
the period is the frequency you could
write the speed as 2 PI R times the
frequency since time is not a vector
these quantities are not vectors and
they cannot be negative so it's an
example involving period and frequency
look like let's say a moon travels
around a planet in a circular orbit of
radius R at a constant speed s we want
to know what the period and frequency
are in terms of given quantities and
fundamental constants so we use the
relationship between the speed the
period and the frequency we know that
for objects in circular motion the speed
is 2 pi R over the period and that means
the period here would be equal to 2 pi R
over the speed and since frequency is 1
over the period if we take 1 over this
quantity we just flip the top and bottom
and we get that this is the speed over 2
pi R but we can't leave our answer in
terms of V we had to express this in
terms of given quantities we were given
s so our answer for the period has to be
2 pi R over s and for frequency it would
be s over 2 PI R which is C what is
centripetal acceleration the centripetal
acceleration of an object is the
acceleration
it's causing that object to go in a
circle and it's important to note that
this centripetal acceleration always
points toward the center of the circle
the formula to find the centripetal
acceleration is speed squared divided by
the radius of the circle the object is
traveling in even though this has a bit
of an exotic formula for the
acceleration it's still an acceleration
so it still has units of meters per
second squared and it is a vector which
means it does have a direction ie toward
the center of the circle but this
centripetal acceleration does not cause
the object to speed up or slow down this
centripetal acceleration is only
changing the direction of the velocity
if the object going in the circle is
also speeding up or slowing down
there's also got to be a component of
the acceleration that's tangential to
the circle in other words if the object
is going in a circle and speeding up
there's got to be a component of
acceleration in the direction of the
velocity and if the object is slowing
down there's got to be a component of
acceleration in the opposite direction
to the velocity so centripetal
acceleration changes the direction of
the velocity and tangential acceleration
changes the magnitude or size of the
velocity but this formula V squared over
R is only giving you the magnitude of
the centripetal acceleration this does
not account for any tangential
acceleration so what's an example
problem involving centripetal
acceleration look like let's say
particle a is traveling in a circle with
a constant speed s and a radius R if
particle B is traveling in a circle with
twice the speed of a and twice the
radius of a what's the ratio of the
acceleration of particle a compared to
particle B so particle a is going to
have a centripetal acceleration of the
speed squared over the radius and
particle B is also going to have an
acceleration of the speed squared but
this speed is twice as much as the speed
of particle a and it's traveling in a
circle with twice the radius of particle
a when we square the two we'll get four
over two gives us a factor of two times
the speed of a squared over the radius
of a so the ratio of the acceleration of
particle a compared to particle B is
going to be one-half since the
acceleration of particle a is half the
acceleration of particle B centripetal
forces are not a new type of force
centripetal forces are just one of the
any other forces that we've
already met that happened to be pointing
toward the center of the circle making
an object to travel in a circle so for a
moon going around the earth gravity is
the centripetal force for a yo-yo going
around on a string the tension is the
centripetal force for a skateboarder
doing a loop-de-loop the normal force is
the centripetal force and for a car
going around a round about the static
frictional force is the centripetal
force and these forces still follow
Newton's second law but using
centripetal forces means you're also
going to have to use the expression for
the centripetal acceleration now if a
force is directed radially inward toward
the center of the circle you would count
that force as positive since it points
in the same direction as the centripetal
acceleration and if a force points
radially out from the center of the
circle you would count that as a
negative force and if a force is
directed tangential to the circle you
wouldn't include it in this calculation
at all you could include those forces in
their own Newton's second law equation
but you wouldn't be using V squared over
R for that acceleration those tangential
forces change the speed of the object
but the centripetal force changes the
direction of the object so what's an
example problem involving centripetal
forces look like imagine a ball of mass
M rolling over the top of the hill of
radius R at a speed s and we want to
know at the top of the hill what's the
magnitude of the normal force exerted on
the ball by the road so we'll draw our
force diagram there's going to be an
upward normal force on the ball from the
road and there's going to be a downward
force of gravity on the ball from the
earth and these two forces are not going
to be equal and opposite if they were
equal and opposite they'd balance and if
the forces are balanced the object would
maintain its velocity and keep traveling
in a straight line but this ball doesn't
travel on a straight line it starts
accelerating downward so this normal
force is going to have to be less than
the force of gravity to figure out how
much less we could use Newton's second
law with the formula for centripetal
acceleration the speed is s the radius
is R the force of gravity is going to be
a positive centripetal force since it's
directed toward the center of the circle
the normal force is going to be a
negative centripetal force since it's
directed radially away from the center
of the circle if we divide by the mass
which if you solve this for normal force
gives you the force of gravity - M s
squared over R which makes sense because
this normal force has to be less than
the force of gravity Newtons you
versal law of gravity states that all
masses in the universe pole ie attract
every other mass in the universe with
gravitational force and this force is
proportional to each mass and inversely
proportional to the square of the center
to Center distance between the two
masses in mathematical form it just says
that the force of gravity is equal to
big G a constant which is six point six
seven times 10 to the negative 11th
multiplied by each mass in kilograms and
then divided by the centre to centre
distance between the two masses in other
words not the surface-to-surface
distance but the centre to centre
distance and even if these two objects
have different masses the magnitude of
the force they exert on each other is
going to be the same this is illustrated
by the formula since you could swap
these two masses and you get the same
number and it's also something we know
from Newton's third law this force of
gravity is a vector and it has a
direction the direction is always such
that it attracts every other mass and
since this is a force that unit is in
Newtons so what's an example problem
involving Newton's universal law of
gravity look like let's say two masses
both of mass M exert a gravitational
force F on each other if one of the
masses is exchanged for a mass 3m and
the center-to-center distance between
the masses is tripled what would the new
gravitational force be we know the
gravitational force is always big G
times one of the masses multiplied by
the other mass divided by the
center-to-center distance squared so the
initial force between the two masses
would be big G M times M over R squared
but the new force with the exchanged
values would be big G times three M
times M divided by three times the
radius squared the factor of three
squared on the bottom gives nine and
three divided by 9 is 1 over three times
big GMM over R squared so we can see
that the force with the new values is
one-third of the force with the old
values what's gravitational field mean
the gravitational field is just another
word for the acceleration due to gravity
near an object you can visualize a
gravitational field as vectors pointing
radially in toward a mass all masses
create a gravitational field that points
radially in toward them and dies off
like 1 over R squared the farther you
get away from them so the formula for
the gravitational field
created by a mass M is big G times the
mass creating the field divided by the
distance from the center of the mass to
the point where you're trying to
determine the value of the field and
again this value for the gravitational
field is going to be equal to the value
for the acceleration due to gravity of
an object placed at that point the
gravitational field is a vector since it
has a direction ie toward the center of
the object creating it and since
gravitational field is equivalent to
acceleration due to gravity the units
are meters per second squared but you
could also write that as Newton's per
kilogram which is another way of
thinking about what gravitational field
means not only is it the acceleration
due to gravity of an object placed at
that point but it's the amount of the
gravitational force exerted on a mass M
placed at that point so you can think of
the gravitational field as measuring the
amount of gravitational force per
kilogram at a point in space which when
rearranged gives you the familiar
formula that the force of gravity is
just M times G so it's an example
problem involving gravitational field
look like let's say a hypothetical
Planet X had three times the mass of
Earth and half the radius of Earth what
would be the acceleration due to gravity
on Planet X ie the gravitational field
on Planet X in terms of the acceleration
due to gravity on earth which is GE so
we know that the gravitational field on
earth has to be big G times mass of the
earth over the radius of Earth squared
which we're calling G sub e and the
gravitational field on Planet X would be
big G times three times the mass of the
earth divided by half the radius of the
earth squared and when we square this
factor of 1/2 we'll get one-fourth which
is in the denominator so 3 divided by
1/4 is 12 times big G mass of the earth
over radius of the earth squared and
since this entire term here is the
acceleration due to gravity on earth the
acceleration due to gravity on Planet X
is going to be 12 times the acceleration
due to gravity on earth sometimes when
you're solving gravitational problems
you'll be given the density instead of
the mass the density is the amount of
mass per volume for a given material the
symbol for density is the Greek letter
Rho and you can find it by taking the
mass divided by the volume so that
units of density are kg/m^3 and it's not
a vector since it has no direction but
it does let you solve for mass if you
know the density you could say that the
mass is the density times the volume so
what's an example problem involving
density look like let's try the
hypothetical planet problem again but
this time instead of being told that
Planet X has three times the mass of
Earth let's say Planet X has three times
the density of Earth and again half the
radius of Earth what would be the
acceleration due to gravity on Planet X
in terms of the acceleration due to
gravity on earth GE we could write down
the formula for gravitational
acceleration or gravitational field
which is big G M over R squared but this
time we don't know the mass we just know
the density so we want to rewrite this
formula in terms of density which we can
do by rewriting the M as Rho times V
since density is mass per volume and
mass is density times volume but we
don't know the volume of this planet we
just know the radius so we need to
rewrite volume in terms of radius which
we could do since planets are spherical
and the volume of a sphere is 4/3 PI R
cubed we can substitute this expression
in for the volume and finally an
expression for the acceleration due to
gravity of big G times Rho 4/3 PI R
cubed divided by R squared and we can
cancel out an R squared on the top and
the bottom which leaves us little G as
equaling big G Rho 4/3 PI R so the
gravitational acceleration on earth
would be big G Rho of earth 4/3 pi times
the radius of Earth and the
gravitational acceleration on Planet X
would be big G times the density of
Planet X which is 3 times the density of
Earth times 4/3 pi times the radius of
Planet X which is 1/2 the radius of
Earth which when we pull out the 3 and
factor of 1/2 gives us three-halves
times the expression for the
acceleration due to gravity on earth so
the gravitational acceleration on Planet
X is going to be 3 halves the
gravitational acceleration on planet
Earth
gravitational orbits are just a special
case of centripetal acceleration where
some object is orbiting another object
due to the gravitational force and if
that orbit is a circle we can relate the
speed the radius of the orbit and the
larger mass to each other using Newton's
second law and centripetal acceleration
you just
in the acceleration as the centripetal
acceleration v squared over R and since
the centripetal force is the force of
gravity you can plug in the expression
for the force of gravity as the
centripetal force which is big GMM over
the distance between them squared and
since the mass of the orbiting object
cancels we get an expression that
relates the speed of the orbiting object
the larger mass that's pulling that
object in and the center-to-center
distance between the objects which if we
solve this for V gives us the square
root of big G times the mass pulling in
the object divided by the
center-to-center distance between the
objects
note that this formula does not depend
on the mass that's in orbit since that
mass cancelled out in the calculation so
what's an example problem involving
gravitational orbits look like well
imagine a space station of mass M s is
orbiting at an altitude of 3r above a
planet of mass M P and radius R as seen
in this diagram and then imagine a
different space station of mass 3m s is
orbiting at an altitude of 2r above a
planet of mass 4m p and a radius of 2 R
as seen in this diagram and we want to
know if the speed of the space station
of mass M s is V then in terms of V
what's the speed of the space station of
mass 3m s well we just show that the
speed of an orbiting object is going to
be equal to the square root of big G
times the mass of the larger object
pulling in the smaller object divided by
the center-to-center distance between
the objects and since this formula
doesn't involve the mass of the orbiting
object it doesn't matter that the
objects have different masses but the
mass of the planet can make a difference
so to get the speed of the space station
to M s we could say that it's the square
root of big G the mass of Planet P over
the center to Center distance which is
not going to be the radius of the planet
or the altitude it's going to be the
radius of the planet plus the altitude
since this has to be the center to
Center distance which in this case will
be 3r plus R which is 4 R and now to get
the speed of the space station of mass
3m s we use the same formula which is
big G mass of the planet which in this
case is 4 MP divided by the center to
Center distance which in this case would
be 2 R plus 2 R and again that's for R
it
we compare the only difference between
these expressions is that there's an
extra factor of four within this square
root so if we take that factor out the
square root of four is two we'd get two
times the expression for the speed of
the spacestation
m/s so the space station 3ms is
traveling two times the speed of the
space station m/s